Wonderboy.
Yeah.
Jon Jones.
Jon Jones,
Jon Jones or stolen.
No,
fucking throwing everything or symbol of kit.
It's a very interesting watching him,
man.
He's doing a lot of sidekicks now and and spinning back kicks.
Turning kicks late into the body.
Yeah,
he saw a lot of sidekicks.
He seats,
he throws a lot of everything man.
But he fucks you up.
He's just,
and he's so good at keeping guys in the back foot and just dismiss,
just taken away their arsenal.
I want to say this though because this is something that's coming up and it's
actually kind of pissing me off.
There's somebody who,
a bunch of people that have been saying,
should Anthony Smith have Tate have like laid down after he took that eel
illegal knee and won the title.
Who set this?
Ariel Helwani a bunch of other people said it.
I think Ariel was suggesting or asking whether or not he should have some Beta
male shit.
Well,
it's crazy because the guy should be praised for he ate the knee.
He was okay and then he wasn't even thinking about quitting.
Yeah.
It even,
I didn't even go through my mind and went through my mind that someone might do
that.
Some people will tell you that day,
Smith,
no,
it wasn't even a thought.
No,
nope,
nope.
It wasn't a thought.
I owned a great one and I wasn't like,
oh,
we should all give him praise for this.
I was like,
well,
no.
Why would he do that?
Well,
that's him.
That's who he is.
But some people like,
let's be honest,
and I think [inaudible] probably admit to this,
if he took that illegal knee,
he might say,
that's it.
Can't go on.
Sorry.
Rematch.
Well,
you get the chills.
Bismuth.
Yeah.
I mean you get the,
when you get the title,
you get a rematch.
I could be wrong.
Shale might disagree.
Might say,
no,
I'm a competitor when I'm in there.
I wouldn't,
wouldn't think that way.
Not,
it is not now his agent,
but the bottom line is like some people were actually,
she actually suggesting that that that would be a good option that he was,
the many people have suggested I saw several PN and that the fans went hard on
these people that suggested it.
Like,
you're out of your fucking mind.
You're out of your fucking mind class.
That'd be such a bitch move.
Unless he actually couldn't go on.
Yeah.
But we all saw he could.
He goes,
I'm fine.
no,
Yeah,
exactly.
What the Smith Think Smith stock went higher now.
Yes.
Go.
Oh Shit.
No,
he's top five for sure.
And he looked very good in the first round.
The first round look.
Very good.
John.
His take down a fence.
Yes.
Very good.
John started figuring them out.
And John John is so good at forcing you to fight his fight and for [inaudible]
and being first.
He's so good at being first.
First with the kicks and the punches first forward.
You know,
he doesn't give you a chance.
And that's the thing with Anthony Smith.
Anthony Smith chance was to always be first if cash Shanthi Smith's fights
prior.
He was a dozer comes at you.
John went,
that's what you do.
Cool.
I'll put you on your back foot.
You go first.
Not In my,
not in my night.
I'm going to go first.
He all done.
Anthony Smith was defensive the entire time.
He just took away all his tools.
He also fought very technically in the first,
first round.
It was,
he didn't just showing Adam Anthony.
Oh yeah.
For a very,
John actually in the first,
Sean got a little wild.
I felt like he almost felt the pressure of being a,
you know,
minus 800 favorite really since never seen John thrilled those wild punches that
first round.
He was trying to get him out of there and they went,
you know what?
This isn't gonna be as easy.
I thought recalculate and then dismantle them.
Yeah.
I mean,
he's the best of all time by far,
by far the best.
But who who,
who in that division can fuck with him now?
I mean [inaudible] which is,
look,
Santos is a wildcard.
That motherfucker can knock out anybody.
I would have liked to see Johnny Walker not below his shoulder out.
Celebrate.
And it's fine though.
What's listen man,
he couldn't move his arm.
He came in the back and they'd even,
they're waiting to,
I think today,
but in the back after he went.
I'm actually good now.
Okay,
so what that must mean.
That must mean that he dislocated it and then they popped it back in place.
So it could be fine or there could be some significant tearing inside that
allowed it to dislocate.
And that can be a problem in the future.
Say it's fine though,
but it's home,
but still not fighting John Jones yet.
He hasn't wasted.
Fill that dude up.
Stem cells.
Just get a bunch of needles in there and fucking Corazon do all the fucking,
no,
no warm Schwann,
bro.
Don't know.
Give them cortisones to give them some stem cells.
So it toast.
Santos is the interesting fight for John.
Yes.
He's interesting because Santos throws fucking nuclear muscles at your head and
you know,
he did stop.
Jimmy knew Mattawa he's,
he stopped several guys at light heavyweight.
He looks spectacular,
light every way,
and he stopped Anthony Smith and their last fight at middleweight.